[Musique]
nous sommes le 22 mai vient me bienvenu
pour cette édition du 7 8 les invités
aujourd'hui en plateau agents à bellamy
c'est le référent du secours populaire
dans les yvelines sur le projet de santé
un projet qui prévoit d'aider les plus
démunis obtenir une couverture santé ou
encore à trouver le professionnel qui
pourra les prendre en charge
jacques segal un médecin bénévole est
également invité à ses côtés et puis je
reçois aussi ce soir antoine goulard et
les membres de l'association rega la
sauce régal et qui s'est fixé comme
objectif de faciliter l'accès de 150
familles lui en courtoise à une
alimentation saine local est accessible
à tous et nous expliquera comment ce
projet prend forme bonsoir à tous les
trois on va débuter avec ce projet santé
face à la montée de la pauvreté
il a été décidé maintenant de constituer
une équipe pour être le relais de ces
personnes vers la santé accès au droit
la prévention la sensibilisation mais
dans une mise en place qui se fait
encore aujourd'hui ou le projet déjà
véritablement lancée pour le secours
populaire
non le projet le secours populaire qui
comme vous savez c'était jusqu'à présent
occupé essentiellement de l'alimentation
et des vêtements ainsi que des vacances
également pour les enfants décidé depuis
deux ans de chaque piquet dans la santé
des bénéficiaires du secours populaire
qui sont environ sept mille huit cents
sur le département des yvelines
donc pour l'instant le
il s'agit essentiellement d'explorer ce
qu'ils sont des besoins des
bénéficiaires
comment on peut s'organiser pour
répondre à ses besoins
et pour cela de constituer une équipe
pour le moment nous sommes deux avec le
docteur segal est bon nous n'avons pas
la prétention d'avoir toutes les bonnes
idées à 2 donc on essaye de recruter
d'autres professionnels de santé
probablement surtout des retraités parce
que les professionnels de santé en
activité et surtout les médecins sont
déjà surchargés de travail et donc on
essaye de recruter des professionnels de
santé pour d'abord constituer une équipe
et ensuite voir comment on pourra
s'organiser pour améliorer pour
retravailler pour la santé les
bénéficiaires du secours populaire
quels sont les besoins qui pour
l'instant remonte ce que vous entendez
le plus souvent de la part des
bénéficiaires du secours populaire c'est
une couverture de santé pouvoir y
accéder
trouver le bon interlocuteur oui c'est à
dire que les on a essayé de former les
bd les bénévoles du secours populaire
français à entrer en contact avec les
bénéficiaires justement pour parler de
santé et pas seulement de vous avez un
colis qui est prêt alimentaire ou
vestimentaire etc
et comme dans toutes les populations
précaires
la santé n'est pas spontanément ce dont
parle tout de suite les gens il faut
pouvoir leur demander s'ils ont un accès
au soin un ciseau pour certains autres
des papiers qui leur permettrait de
demander une aide médicale ou et c'est
ça demande du temps ça de loin de la
voûte d'avoir d'abord la volonté de le
faire ça veut dire aussi que certains
bénéficiaires pourraient bénéficier de
certaines aides aussi mais nous sommes
au courant en fait simplement parce que
tout est très compliqué aujourd'hui
différents textes et donc
identifiés sur ces bonbons que quatre
problèmes qui sont l'accès au droit
le l'orientation dans le système de
santé qui n'est pas toujours simple pour
une personne surtout si elle n'a pas
beaucoup de relations de deux s'il a
beaucoup de problèmes par ailleurs
l'éducation à la santé et éventuellement
les soins alors vraiment les soins
infirmiers et médicaux qui pose problème
donc produit des droits des
bénéficiaires
on sait que parce que pour le rsa à peu
près 20% des personnes qui ont droit au
rsa on ne le demande pas parce que
parfois de 16 secondes parce quoi parce
que c'est que c'est compliqué elles ne
savent pas et savent à qui s'adresser et
certainement le problème est le même
pour le droit à la santé
il ya des personnes qui ont droit à une
couverture santé ou à une aide à la
complémentaire santé par exemple qui ne
demandent pas parce que c'est compliqué
je vais rappeler quand même aussi
quelques chiffres aujourd'hui un
français sur cinq retard de ses soins où
il renonce totalement la tendance se
répand de plus en plus parmi ces
populations fragilisées par la crise à
47 % de chômeurs les étudiants aussi à
20% sont dépourvus de couverture maladie
les soins dentaires et les lunettes
c'est les premiers postes de soins qui
sont sacrifiés c'est ce que vous
considérez aussi sur le terrain il y
avoue secours populaire il ya 25
structures qui sont des antennes locales
des comités etc et qui touchent à peu
près 7000 personnes
pour les fds et donc c'est un très grand
nombre de gens qui ont besoin d'être et
qui ont aussi besoin des aides à la
santé comme on voit dans les autres
associations qui s'occupent des
personnes en situation de précarité et
on voit de plus en plus de gens qui
n'ont aucun accès aux soins parce
qu'aucun papier parce que ce sont des
migrants ainsi qu'ils sont en situation
irrégulière est ce que aujourd'hui le
secours populaire dans les yvelines aide
ces personnes
est ce qu'il ya des consultations
médicales qui sont organisées ou est-ce
qu'on est sur une aide pour accéder aux
soins pour bien comprendre les personnes
qui pourraient écouter et être
intéressés de se dire on peut m'aider
est-ce que ça va les guider
c'est d'abord l'accès et ensuite pour le
moment il existe le choco populaire ne
fait pas de soins n'y a pas d'hopital de
secours populaire on n'envisage pas d'en
construire un ou même à dispensaire
secours populaire il existe dans les
yvelines deux associations de médecins
mais c'est un bénévole sur saint quentin
en yvelines et médecins de rue à
versailles qui donnent des soins aux
personnes défavorisées
mais pour le moment le secours populaire
n'envisage pas de faire des du soin donc
elle ce pôle santé en tout cas qui se
met en place pour aider pour guider les
fermiers un petit peu les besoins qui
pourrait qui pourrait n'être donc on va
afficher un une fois de plus à l'antenne
les le site internet et puis l'adresse
mail aussi ainsi vous êtes vous voulez
être bénévole et puis à participer à ce
sujet est né cherche des bénévoles
les profils sont les bienvenus pour vous
aider ces personnes qui étaient autour
de l'aspect qui vaille autour de la
santé infirmières centre
psychothérapeutique qui les kinés le
personnel aussi des sciences sociales le
personnel des caisses de sécurité
sociale
la répression et les maisons place vous
allez faire un bilan un point et pouvoir
lancer dans tout ça quand tu deviens mon
objectif car il faisait dans quelques
mois on espérait créer une équipe et
puis se mettre au point alors de manière
plus pointue notre projet et puis le
lancer est on bien sûr on relira tout ça
sur notre antenne je rappelle l'adresse
du site internet secours populaire point
fr slash 78e puis l'adresse mail aussi
qui s'est affichée merci à vous deux res
était resté en plateau on va parler
d'une autre initiative avec vous antoine
goulard vous êtes membre de la sauce
régal vous êtes chargé de la
communication
le plan d'action de cette association
est baptisé en route vers l'autonomie
alimentaire alors ça consiste en quoi
précisément alors c'est consiste
fédérer recensé 150 familles et
courtoise pour les aider à accéder à une
alimentation saine et locale
il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
une situation climatique compliquée
depuis la côte 21 on sait que le risque
d'augmenter le réchauffement climatique
et plus de 4 degrés est élevé et chacun
doit faire sa part
on a eu un court on a décidé de faire
notre part en relevant le défi en
octobre dernier de créer une association
qui va transformer la ville comment ça
va fonctionner concrètement ce projet
pour permettre l'accès à 150 familles à
une alimentation saine locales et
accessible ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'il ya déjà des maraîchers qui sont
sur le territoire il ya également des
plus en plus de producteurs locaux qui
essaye de faire des produits sains et
locaux
nous ce qu'on souhaite faire c'est
mettre en place des circuits courts qui
va faciliter l'accès en éduquant
démarche des supermarchés qui qui élève
le prix et les rend inaccessibles au
plus grand nombre et également ont
également informé la population de ce
qui existe par des événements d'occuper
des voisins qu'on a fait tiens dernier
week end a mis tout à fait rassemble
plus de 80 personnes nous avons servi à
50 repas bio et nous pensons à berck et
aussi des collectivités territoriales
par une autre action de façon à ce
qu'elles facilitent l'accès aux
agriculteurs aux terrains illinois qui
existent mais qui demeure sous exploité
par rapport à ce qui est possible il ya
eu des précédents organisé en france qui
vous ont servi d'exemple un petit peu
quelque chose de totalement innovant on
est sur quelque chose de totalement
éléments après un déjeuner dynamique qui
aussi alternatiba le grand défi je pars
tous les citoyens dans l'aude ils se
prennent en main pour participer à la
transition écologique et donc nous on a
dû en cours on relève aussi cette ce
défi en soi sans en six ans pour
objectif de fédérer 150 familles du
encore gaz qui vont aller là dessus et
notamment notre projet qui est approche
va consister à créer une épicerie
participative très prochainement qui va
viser justement à rendre accessible plus
facilement ses produits locaux à un prix
défiant toute concurrence et qui
permettent à l'exploitant aussi aux
producteurs d'en vivre tout à fait signe
objectif avec un objectif de solidarité
c'est du commerce équitable nord sud
effectivement on est vraiment dans une
démarche de d'accompagner les
producteurs dans leurs installations de
façon à permettre de relocaliser
l'emploi également
on a deux sur une problématique de
justice sociale aussi est ce que la
municipalité vous êtes dans ce projet là
tout à fait la municipalité avance de
plus en plus et elle est elle même une
autre pique nique de gaza ce samedi est
elle annoncée dès le projet sur la
petite lumière qui un terrain que nous
souhaiterions voir
être nagui culture locale et saine et
notamment s'est engagé à l'installation
de ses amis municipal pour faire pousser
les plantes de l'effort de la ville mais
également l'installation de ruches et
pour permettre une production locale de
miel et de tenter un verger municipal
notamment pour permettre aux cantines
d'être alimenté la pomme bio donc pour
mieux s'aimer excellente nouvelle on
nous espérons que cette politique doit
se poursuivre et s'amplifier parce que
on n'est pas loin de l'emballement
climatique c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné on va arriver le ciel de
réchauffement qui va inévitablement
s'accélérer
donc il faut éviter ça et du coup
transformé la ville au plus vite
vous parliez de 150 familles les encours
toit ce qui pourrait bénéficier de ce
service là comment vous les recenser
cette famille ces familles c'est encore
en cours voilà en fait on prévoit dans
cette action qui va perdre en valais
discuter avec les gens leur proposer un
formulaire pour se renseigner sur leurs
habitudes alimentaires sur leurs trajets
quotidiens et sûreté supermarché est
fréquente et on va identifier les freins
qu'ils soient sociaux économiques ou
bien en termes d'accès de façon à
produire une petite analyse que le
publierons sur notre site et qui
permettra à tous les acteurs qui
souhaitent s'installer dans le coin pour
ce type d'alimentation pour soi le la
produire ça pour la distribuer de
disposer de données fiables et
accessibles donc en là on est vraiment
dans une dans un engagement de recherche
sociologique mais tout en étant dans une
action politique pour transformer la
ville
là le site internet s'affiche également
l'adresse mail si vous souhaitez rentrer
en contact avec l'association pour aussi
y participer en savoir un petit peu plus
une dernière question l'idée c'est de
développer encore plus 150 familles
s'est dans un premier temps j'imagine
voilà peut-être que la prochaine c'est
jusqu'en novembre notre plan d'action
après peut-être que on passera à 250
cinq cents peut-être qu'on s'occupera
aussi d'autres deux thématiques comme le
déplacement une énergie renouvelable est
exclue on est une association
généraliste sur tout ce qui touche à la
justice sociale et au climat et on
entend le poursuivre on a déjà 60
adhérents on s'est créé en octobre on
amène une amap
on va bientôt animer une épicerie
participative voilà c'est peut-être
d'autres circuits courts aussi voilà on
a parlé de deux initiatives aujourd'hui
qui se déroule sur bassin de saint
quentin en yvelines merci anthony
goulard donc le rappelle le site
internet entre autres associations qui
s'est affichée la sauce point régal
points le bio pour participer à l'
enquête en savoir plus et peut-être
proposer d'autres idées de projets du
côté de guyancourt voir dans le reste du
département et puis jacques ce gars les
gens belani
merci à vous également je rappelle ce
projet du secours populaire français
autour d'une santé pour tous et là aussi
on vous renvoie vers le site internet du
spf 78 à la fin du set 8 heures invités
pour ce soir replay sur notre site
internet et on se retrouve demain avec
de nouveaux invités
merci à vous
[Musique]